I in case you have not noticed it is
very cold outside in most of America how
cold is it so cold that sharks are
freezing to death in Cape Cod so called
the annual Polar Bear Plunge is around
the country being canceled so cold
cities are scrapping their New Year's
Eve countdowns not this one though
don't worry Kennedy no it's so cold the
president he's still got to come to work
defending his decision again to pull us
out of the climate deal in light of the
Arctic temperatures for example I have a
tweet of his in the East it could be the
coldest New Year's Eve on record the
president tweets perhaps we could use a
little bit of that good old global
warming that our country , but not other
countries , again was going to pay
trillions of dollars to protect against
bundle up exclamation point thank you
hey Gore issued that dire warning seven
years ago while accepting his Nobel
Peace Prize that the entire polar ice
cap they disappear by 2014 scientists
reported with unprecedented alarm that
the north polar ice cap is in their
words falling off a cliff one study
estimated that it could be completely
gone during summer in less than 22 years
another new study to be presented by US
Navy researchers later this week warns
it could happen in as little as seven
years seven years from now all those
people were sitting there shivering in
fear wondering when Al Gore was gonna
stop talking or start 2006 he also said
within the next 10 years the world reach
a point of no return we're past that
point of no return so the president
tweets out and they say oh my goodness
he's a he doesn't like science Marie
harf he says global warming can't happen
if we're freezing to death is he right
no he's trolling liberals that's what
he's doing here what climate change
doesn't mean that it can't be cold and
depending on where you live hot gets
hotter cold gets colder last year was
the hottest year on record the year
before that with the second hottest year
on record he does not understand climate
science but his administration actually
does Al Gore the scientific agencies in
the Trump administration affirmed the
global warming is real and the humans
are the quick
warming or climate change Manhattan's
about the terminology I agree with you
that that the climate is certainly
changing and weird stuff is going on and
we can't necessarily control it the part
that we can control we have to look at
that logically and rationally and not
emotionally and I think that has been
very problematic it's almost like a
religion and it is it is incredibly
dogmatic and if you disagree with it
people like Tim Cook say you should be
thrown in prison I don't disagree with
it but I love actual science and science
is based in rationality so what do we do
now how much of our economy do sacrifice
things in order to fix the problems you
you have to sacrifice it I mean clean
energy is actually an economic job
creator they are making huge profits
where they're subsidized by the
government and coal is subsidized much
more than clean energy when no it's not
wind solar go to a state like Texas or
where they're subsidized ten to one
where it's go to a sale in Taiwan is
where they are the high vineyard
unspoiled yes they are also investing on
it in solar and wind at historic rates
and their energy costs are going down
and they're helping save the great one
thing they are tracking tracking is much
better for the planet
Tom come down ok let somebody else get a
word I'm a Jedi I can't come down say
anything butthat was the according to Al
Gore Manhattan was going to be under
water because of Greenland ice melt
Kilimanjaro was going to be snow free
and we would be battling rapidly rising
temperatures and struggle more frequent
storms and I hadn't totally been under
water once in the last few years it's
true what's your reaction the polar bear
would so it wasn't president Trump wrong
to believe that out know he's he is
trolling I'll agree with Marie harf on
that trolling but that's what he does
he's in everyone's losing their minds
the thing is I want to stop having this
argument about is it or isn't it because
now we have the people they call them
deniers but on the other side I call
them the explainers the explainers are
saying well no it's the solar winds and
the solar winds wouldn't be happening
everyone for eight you know I'm sick of
the explainers the thing is I want to
talk about the fact that carbon
emissions the one solution that people
have on the lab right is cap the carbon
hurt our economy that's not a good
solution it's not the one solution
that's not also what all you guys
sellin carbon right that's America's
private place that's the person pulled
out of right it's just I'm tired of
celebrities like Leonardo DiCaprio who
owns a big yacht and a private jet to
fly to the UN to give us a lecture about
how we need to do less for the planet
well you can start first of all the
second thing is there's a difference
between pollution and climate change are
there things that we have done in the
United States to stop pollution to clean
up the environment absolutely we should
be doing more of that China and India
should be do they are that China and
India I accept the premise that the
climate is changing it has been changing
for billions of years I'm from Arizona
it used to be under an ocean you can
find seashell fossils at the top of the
North Rim of the Grand Canyon now I'm
going to get a lecture about the
difference between weather and climate
change not a lecture fact is that the
planet has been changing for a very long
time and we shouldn't throw our economy
away to try and act like we can control
one or two but I love the idea I don't
think we need big government solutions I
love technology if there are companies
that allow me to drive around a Willie
Nelson the tour bus that is fueled by
biodiesel or or a Partridge Family bus
which seemed very gassy for a
Flintstones Buster you can just then you
know go ahead let's embrace the future
all right I think that was a wonderful
way to end thank you Brian that's
fantastic